全记的国民性它不是一日之工，可以说国民性是他们的来处。
人们对某段经历的整体评价主要是基于高峰，还有就是你体验的结尾，而其他的时段往往是不会被纳入到评估之中的。
说到东方美学，也许我们应该先聊一下这个词，为什么我们不说中国风或者是新中式，就这两个我们在日常中提的更多的词呢？
欢迎收听雨光post，这是一档关于品牌解析的播客，从市场逻辑与文化美学两端出发，一起探究那些真正打动过我们的品牌。
大家好，我是惠斯，我是Jackie。
今天我们探讨的品牌是全剂酒店，不知道有多少听友住过全剂酒店呢？
住得多的估计也都没少出差，全剂酒店是一个风格非常清晰的品牌。
不知道有多少人和我一样提起这个品牌，立刻会想到它标志性的寿常型的字体，就隐隐暗示了它的中式风格。
那眼下，新中式中国风已经渐渐成为主流，但是全剂早在15年前，
这是在酒店还追求奢华的国际化的氛围下，就非常领先于时代的确定了东方美学的风格。
那我们今天就来探讨一下，全剂最初定位于谁，想明白了什么才确立了这个风格。
那东方美学是如何渗透进我们的日常，在不经意间就让我们血脉觉醒。
以及全剂与亚朵的差异与较量反映出近十年来，我们的消费行为发生了怎样不知不觉间的偏移。
好，我们开始。
全剂酒店啊，我还是挺有感情的，就多少个出差的日日夜夜都是在全剂里度过的。
出差是吧，就是我住全剂也是因为出差，看来咱俩场景差不多。
那你先说说对全剂的印象吧，就我想知道设计师角度的全剂是怎么样的一个存在。
就是现在好多酒店，不多说自己是设计师酒店嘛，就我们的设计师出差啊，就不住设计师酒店，反而住在全剂。
你说来让我们听听看啊，主要是设计师酒店，它是设计师设计的，它不是给设计师住的，我们住也没有折扣，所以还是全剂性价比高嘛。
那说回到全剂，可能因为是酒店嘛，我觉得核心它就是个睡觉的地方，所以晚上待的时间比较久。
就因为这个，所以我对它最明显的印象是它的照明，就是我脑子里会先浮现出的画面是它房间内不同区域的柔和的灯光，还有就是床头有好几个灯的开关那个样子。
全剂的照明总给我感觉弱弱的，但是不昏暗，它有很多层次待在里面还是挺舒缓的嘛。
我曾经看到过就是有杂志，它提到过全剂的光线设计，是确实是比一般的经济连锁酒店花了更多心思去尝试的。
对它在设计这个光线的时候，其实是没有用酒店业的一些通用模板，而是定制了它的专属方案，让照度还有光线语言有变化。
说到这的话，我会想到其实光本身对人类就是一个非常重要的主题。
所以在艺术创作当中也会有很多关于光的实验，比如说像安藤忠雄，他很标志性的光之教堂，就是通过从缝隙透出来的光去建立精神中心，就是这样的一个设计吧。
对，那我们生活中比较近的例子其实就是我们的家，大家如果刷那个装修的话题的话，可能会发现近几年很多人在说无主灯，氛围灯什么的。
像同一个房间改变光的话，你甚至可以改变它的气氛和用途。
这个我刚刚经历过，我们家也是无主灯设计，尤其卧室。
我在装修的时候，就是曾经看过一个设计师的装修万里总结。
他说有一阵子就很流行，就是餐桌上只装一盏吊灯，而且这盏吊灯它正好位于餐桌正中心的上方。
所以灯一亮，餐厅一下子就变成了审讯室。
桌子对面人的眼窝，鼻子下面全都是阴影，如果再是一个白光的话，那真的就是问话现场。
但是我看到了这样的一个案例，我才意识到，原来灯光它是一个系统，有了管氛围，有了管照明，它需要协调呼应才会有温馨的效果。
嗯，是的，是的，你说到这个，我想起以前的酒店，房间里确实都会有一个顶灯，而且那个酒店大堂里会有大吊灯，
他们的存在感都特别的重，而且我觉得甚至可以说是一种权力感非常重。
有时候我呆在里面就会不自觉的觉得紧张和压迫，而相比之下，拳技呢，就与其说是在不知光，
我觉得不如说是在不知暗，它用暗去构成了一种温柔的秩序，而光呢，就是用我们的话说叫功成而服居的感觉，
就是他爸该做的事做了，但是他浅浅的就退下去了，不是很骄傲的那种感觉。
那会是你呢，提到拳技酒店你是有怎样的印象呢？
我作为用户最能体会的是温，就是温度的那个温，我自己是非常不喜欢大理石元素的，
因为它碰上去凉凉的，我也不喜欢瓷砖，就是那种地砖，因为脚踩上去会觉得冰，觉得硬。
那我们家装修是通出目的版，包括厨房、阳台，甚至厨房的台面也是木质的。
就是只有卫生间他必须要防水，我才选了瓷砖去铺那个地。
所以对我来讲，就是让我放松戒备的酒店就一定要温，不能豪，就是豪华会让我产生等级感，权威感。
那拳技会用很多的木质材料也是反奢华的，所以这一点还是比较适合我的。
是，我们之前也说过材质跟人的心理联统是很强的，
现在回想起来，小的时候住的酒店在材质选择方面其实没有那么准确的。
那时候只有大酒店和小旅馆，就简单的只能划分成这两种对。
你钱花到位了，就必须要上大理石，大调灯，他才能谈生意，才能有面子。
那你钱不够呢，就只能是瓷砖，然后干净能睡觉就可以了。
这两个路线现在来看，其实已经不再能回答我们的需求了。
是，那个时候的路线是没有美学分层，它只有用料的成本分层。
可能是人们从物质匱乏的年代走来，就是弥补最快的方式就是显贵的，就是显豪华的，
就是这样的一种补偿形态。
那我们下面就跳回到时代里，就回望一下拳技诞生的时机。
拳技是在2010年成立的，就听起来不太远，其实已经是15年前了呀，我们的听优吧，时间过得很快。
那它是一个典型的，现在已经比较少见的瞄准南海市场的成功案例。
那这个南海市场指的是谁呢，就是出差人群。
那拳技出现的时间节点很有意思啊，就是2010年左右是中国商业活动的黄金十年。
就是古话说嘛，天下兮兮皆为历来，天下嚷嚷皆为历往。
这是一个非常务实的观察，商业繁荣，人就会频繁的流动，有流动就会有住宿需求。
那拳技就赶上了这波大的浪潮，当然这是一个大背景。
比这个更关键的，更重要的一点是一个非常具体的市场变化，就是差率，报销，标准逐渐成为了企业标配，
就是在那个时间节点，并且成为了节日常管理的一部分。
一开始是一些外企，还有上市企业带的头，但是慢慢的大多数企业都满上了这部分管理制度，
并且把住宿标准设定在了300-500这个区间。
那这个价格区间恰好是经济型酒店，比如说拳技之前是儒家汉亭，是这些酒店的上限。
但它又是传统四星级酒店的下限。
所以这中间出现了一个巨大的市场空档，就是这个gap拳技发现了。
你说到报销，我想到前两天刚看了一个搞笑的视频。
就是老板问员工，说你出差为什么一晚上就花了1300。
员工说，因为我们公司规定说经理以下的酒店标准是每晚不能超过300。
老板说，那去掉300，剩下的1000是怎么回事呢？
员工说，因为这个城市没有300亿下的酒店，
所以我们只能去旁边的城市住，然后花1000块钱，打车往返。
别人还挺机智的。
这个场景的太真实了，就是既荒谬又合理，
我觉得属于上班族的日常魔幻了。
真的有这种是吗？
有啊，你一定要符合公司的报销流程，
要不然你过不去那一面，
但是你可以通过一些其他的办法去完成这件事。
还有一个给人类似感觉的场景，就是贴发票。
我不知道听过多少同事报员，
为什么线上化电子化都发展到这个份儿上了，
我们还要攒发票贴发票。
因为报销的时候，就是我们要把发票、小票之类的票据，
沾到一张A字纸上，再交给方便财务核对。
我之前在资金公司工作过四年，
这个公众出差是日常。
我记得我当时的高级经理一个月有20天都在外地，
为数不多在本地办公室工作的几天，
还要拿出一整天时间，
什么都不干，就专门贴发票去走这个报销流程。
我们收回权际以及他的目标人群，
大家发现没，这些人是画像很清晰的一群人，
特征甚至包括痛点都特别集中，
大家可以想象一个15年前常常出差的人，
你会发现他的选择很尴尬。
如果网上就选了四星酒店，
超过了报销标准，就过不去那个界面。
如果往下选连锁经济酒店，
那基本上就是一张床，没有舒适的办公空间。
对，尤其对于我这种数字游民，
纯粹去度假也是必须背着电脑的。
所以传统的酒店它会有那种会客大厅，
我基本上是用不上的，
但权际的大厅是有带充电口的长桌，
我就确实在那上面加过班了。
你看，驻拳机的人不是大老板，
他虽然叫商务酒店，
而是被部门派去的打工人，
或者说像Jackie这种有交付任务的数字游民，
他们都是早早就要起床，考察项目，
晚上回到酒店可能还要打开电脑，
改东西的那种状态。
所以如果一个人总处在危紧张的状态下，
就是那种有东西要交，有事要办的这种状态下，
他渴望什么，又害怕什么呢？
他怕荣誉凡妇，
所以那种欧式风格装修的酒店里，
华丽的石膏纹理，
就是那种红红黄黄的质文地毯，
这些都是信息过彩的，让人心烦意乱的，
但是东方的减约留白，
就恰恰能创造一种减压的氛围。
是的，你说的这个我也很理解，
就是旅行或出差中，
常常会处于一种身份不稳定的状态，
我既不是度假阶层，也不是劳动底层，
我会出现在陌生的城市，
但是又必须要保持效率和体面，
所以氛围的中性对于我来说是很重要的，
就是要它既不过于居家，又不过于商务，
能让我在失去的移动中短暂的恢复一点点秩序感。
对，就是这种秩序感，
全际选择了用东方减约去提供这份中性的秩序感，
那么我们开篇曾经提到过，
全际在十五年前就非常先锋地选择了东方美学这样的整体风格，
这种风格的出现其实是来源于用户洞察，
全际的用户不是游客，而是游目的工作者，
他们的核心需求不是观光体验，而是高效充电，
所以宁静舒适服务的点到为止，说不上多奇特，
但就是这群人此刻的真实需求。
我们既然说到东方美学，
也许我们应该先聊一下这个词，
就为什么是东方美学，
为什么我们不说中国风，
或者是新中市，
就这两个我们在日常中提的更多的词呢？
这个有点复杂，
我们得慢慢去说，
首先在词语的选择上，
我个人是比较纠结的，
比如说中国风这个词，
它其实是一个艺术史上的专有名词，
就法语叫Sinoiserie，
有的时候也会被翻译成中国热，
但它呢是欧洲人基于中国的想象，
然后杂柔了亚洲其他国家的文化和习俗，
这样搞出来的一个二创，
其实和真正的中国传统，
简直就是天差地别了，
不过我们说东方美学，
东方这个词严格来讲，
它跟刚才我说的那个Sinoiserie中国风，
也存在一样的问题，
首先虽然我们自己啊，
习惯说我们东方人，
然后他们西方人什么什么的，
但其实对于欧美来说，
东方人不是指咱们，
而是指中东就是一千零一那块，
其次就是在全球的语境里，
Oriento这个词呢，
它早就从风格术语退场了，
其实原因很简单，
就是它带有强烈的塌热化，
东方风格不是一个自我定义，
就像我们每个人，
就是我们自己个人啊，
都是自己世界的主角，
你是想谁会喊自己叫东方呢，
那我们是相对谁而言的东，
那中心在哪里呢，
所以这个就很奇怪，
所以东方它不是一种风格，
而是一种暗示的一种被观看的方式，
先开始说东方的人，
它暗示的是，
我是这里的观察者定义者，
而他们，
也就是他所谓的东方，
其实是被观察，
被描述，
被定为者，
所以我对东方这个词，
也是会有一点点心理上的小疑虑的，
一开始我觉得你这个多少是，
有点咬文嚼字，
但是我听起来，
其实它不光是为了，
去纠正这个东西，
而是,
其实是在明学中角度，
是谁在看谁的问题，
说这个我也有感觉，
就是我现在在上海生活嘛，
所以我总会跟周围人介绍自己说，
我是北方人，
就是我去解释，
为什么我听不懂上海话，
但如果我还在老家天津生活，
或者是，
就是在北方地区生活，
比如在北京啊，
就是河北之类，
我没有场合说我自己是北方人，
对,
不胜理成章呀，
你说北方人这个，
我日常生活中，
会发生一个类似的事情，
就是我生活在法国，
我对于法国人来说，
我在这片土地，
我是外国人对吧，
但是我们一群中国人，
在评论法国人的时候，
还会说他们外国人，
其实明明我们才是外国人，
对,
但是因为我们，
我们是自我中心的，
我即使我人在国外，
我还认为这个遍地的原住民，
都是外国人，
就这么说来，
就是东方美学，
不是一个客观的说法，
那,
为什么我们还要去用它，
不说全地是中国风，
那中国风它有什么问题呢？
对我而言，
原因有两个，
首先是，
我必须要承认我在这里，
用东方美学这个词，
仅仅是基于，
我们中国人的语境为前提了，
咱不管学术，
或者外国人怎么看待，
就是我们日常聊天，
比如说用到东方美学这个词，
大家是可以无障碍交流的，
它是一个模糊的说法，
只是在这里，
简单粗暴地去，
传达一些意境和感觉，
然后再来，
第二个原因呢，
就是,
我们为什么不用中国风，
或者说中式去形容拳击呢？
比如我们跳出来看，
拳击的风格，
到底有没有到中式这个程度，
它对中式的展现，
又有多少呢？
从我的角度来讲，
我认为，
拳击的特点，
它是在于，
实现了传统美学的现代化，
就是从我们本身的。
深沉复杂的文化当中，
提炼一些适应，
现代社会传播，
适应工业化市场化的一些元素，
去展开，
然后构建出品牌的东方感，
如果说拳击是中式，
是国风的话，
可能对于这个品牌来说，
太重了，
也容易把中式传统，
搞得太浓统了，
实际上呢，
就是它用的木色，
产意啊，等等的，
假想对一个外国人来说，
从视觉体验上，
说它是日本或者韩国，
也都能成立，
是有点，
比如说我看到过网友，
中国的网友说，
他会觉得拳击酒店，
是一种无印良品的感觉，
那其实这个情况，
它的核心是因为，
我们刚才说的所有的这些，
都是一种，
叫做汉字文化圈的气质，
然后还真有这个，
汉字文化圈，
学术上有这样的一个圈是吧，
其实是受儒家文化影响，
对，受儒家文化影响，
受古代中国的文化影响，
然后有汉字使用习惯，
就是这一类的东西，
它不再用国别去定义它，
因为这个，
就很复杂嘛，
它的这个文化的成型啊，
扭转啊什么的，
所以学术上会管这个，
叫做汉字文化圈，
就是Synthe Fair这个词，
对，一种气质，
确实是，
说不清道不明一种，
类似的气质。
所以,
你刚才的意思是说，
中国,
真正的中国风，
这片汪洋大海中，
全际就取了一条来用，
而且这一条是一个。
现代中国人，
甚至是外国人都能够感知到的，
就是,
可以说是门槛不高的一条，
是这个意思了。
对对对，
我觉得全际的这种美学呢，
是在适应现代人的。
生活和情绪的需求，
做个比喻就是，
他像一碗白粥，
不需要复杂的工序，
但他好接受，
然后家家户户，
确实都吃，
所以策略上来讲呢，
也算是减轻了，
文化深度带来的重量，
让他能够更轻盈的去流通，
既不抛弃传统，
也不抵抗现代，
而是找到了一个
良者皆可被感知的温层。
其实对于大部分中国人来说，
传统的中国文化，
其实我们自己是一致拌解的，
就我就拿我自己举例子，
就是我每次去博物馆，
如果不认真听讲解，
或者是缠着DeepSick问了，
真的是看不懂，
或者说看不出，
这个展品有什么特别？
前阵子我去上海的。
红山文化，
有一个展览，
然后里面展出了很多。
觉醒的御龙，
然后我就不懂了，
什么是觉醒，
那个觉就是一个王子旁，
一个觉别的觉的右半部分，
然后我一查发现说，
觉就是有一道缺口的御环，
那后来觉的这道缺口。
被赋予了特殊的文化内涵，
就是断绝，
比如说在红蛮宴中，
泛增多次举起御绝，
暗示相语去除掉流邦，
那在一些明清的张卉小说里面，
也出现过一个人留下御绝，
表示和另一个人断绝关系的情结，
就是也是很含蓄的那种，
但是相比之下，
如果留下的是御环，
这个意思就完全相反了，
因为环它的协议是归环，
表达的是我希望可以归环，
希望我们可以团圆。
是的，就古人，
尤其是知识阶层，
它会佩戴御，
而且对御的分类用法都暗输于心，
那现代人已经不再保留这个传统习惯了，
但是也不能说全都丢了，
因为我觉得中国的文化有一个特点，
这个让它和西方文化分化开来，
就是中国的文化是网状的，
这个特点一直都在，
其实现在它都还在，
它是我们的一个独特之处。
中国文化是网状的，
就是网状就是什么意思？
对，先说这个网状嘛，
网状就是，
我认为中国文化它有一个核心的特征，
就是不可拆分性，
我们的传统文化中知识是一种格局，
不同的学科互为前提，
任何一处震动，
其他的也都会引起共鸣，
会有一种全体共鸣的感觉，
像儒家传统讲究的，
一个东西叫做君子六义，
也就是基础的六种才能，
它是礼乐、社育、书书嘛，
然后你是全都要学的，
所以传统来讲，一个人不可能，
只经通中文诗，
却完全不了解中国的礼和宇宙观，
你甚至都不能不通音律，
因为你别的都不懂的话，
你是不可能在诗词方面成为专才的。
我完全想到一个中国文化和西方文化的不同，
中国是关系性思维，
这个可能也能够回应你刚才说的中国文化是网状的嘛，
那西方是对象性的思维，
就是偏单点的那种思维，
所以中国的底层价值观认为，
就是千疑发而动全身，
这不就是一张网嘛，
但西方那是针对一个局部去做实验，
就是去看我到底改变了什么条件，
它的结果就会不同。
嗯，是的是的，
像我前几天就和一个，
就见到一个朋友，
他是一个白人，
他最近痴迷于八字命理，
然后他就在跟我去讲嘛，
对，他向我去显示，
他心学的这些东西，
他跟我说啊，
Jackie，你的命是因购的，
我就问他什么是因购的，
我就跟他聊嘛，
后来我发现他其实说的这个因购的，
那个因是阴阳的因，
然后购的就是金命，
但是我们中国人就传统的是，
管这个东西叫做新金，
因为金它是分新金跟更金，
但是它呢，
就是一个外国人，
他通过外国专家那一套学来，
就简单粗暴的只剩下阴阳了，
我就跟他解释说，
这个东西你不能这么简化，
因为新耕，
它涉及到了意象，
还有方位、时辰等等，
就是有具体的某种关系的潜台词，
他就觉得很纳闷，
他说,
你可以简单讲明白的东西，
你为什么要扯其他的，
反正最后就是结果就是说不通，
我也不懂一个外国人，
怎么在这件事上，
比我一个中国人还自信，
反正我发现他们好像，
不太能get那种，
此消彼长啊，
还有牵制渗透这些抽象的感知，
因为就像惠斯你刚才说的，
中国人他更倾向于关系性思维，
西方人倾向于对象性思维，
就是这个道理，
我没学过阴阳八卦，
但是比如说你说，
水命啊，
就无需解释，
我就知道他和火命，
大概是哪种不同，
还有一个，
我觉得很多人都遇到过，
遇到老外，
就是给他们解释，
什么是上火这个概念，
就是,
你的外国人解释不明白，
为什么你脸上几个痘痘，
就和火和fire有关，
但是每个人都懂这个火是什么，
我们这几代人，
都是从西方可验症的教育系统中，
被培养出来的，
所以咱们现在人在具体做事的层面上，
已经很稀释思维了，
就比如说，
数据分析这项工作，
如果分析什么呢，
其实就是做实验，
就是刚才说的，
西方那种对象性思维嘛，
比如说我做了ABC，
三种不同策略，
哪个,
让整体，
让大盘长了，
然后我们去验证它是否有效，
所以整体说来，
一方面，
我们好像都懂一些，
但另外一方面，
在具体的日常生活中，
就我们已经用到了，
很多西方人那种对象性思维了，
是的,
我们不可否认，
我们生活在一个全球化，
现代化的社会当中，
从教育体系到审美，
社会结构，
还有商业认知，
它离传统已经很远了，
对,
所以这个某种程度上，
也让我们成为了，
自己文化的踏着，
日常没有条件，
支持我们，
把自己的文化，
像古代人一样，
去吃透，
比如说刚才，
卉斯妮提到的这个，
欲绝,
那在这种事情上，
涉及,
简直是，
重灾区，
比如说，
一提到中国传统，
那前些年，
很多人，
就会用龙袍，
大红色，
和青花籽，
去表现，
就感觉，
几千年的历史，
结果搞来搞去，
最后就只剩下这三套了，
因为,
在现代，
快速,
高效的商业传播，
它是承受不起，
太复杂的符号的，
这是一件没办法的事情，
所以这么说，
就是,
我们,
这一代人吧，
就是,
更多是现代人的成分，
而不是传统中人的成分，
所以,
东方美学，
就恰好适配了，
我们的这个，
接受范围，
是的,
我觉得，
拳技肯定是知道这个道理的，
所以它找到了，
东方美学，
这么一个调和技，
去调和，
现代,
与传统之间的平衡，
弥补这种，
快速发展，
所产生的锻炼，
就如同，
用普通话，
去注解，
中国古诗词，
一样,
也可以理解，
就好像是，
如果古照那一句，
都用文言文来说台词，
或者说，
不用现在的普通话，
是用唐朝的那种，
官话的那种，
唐音来念，
就是，大家也听不懂吧，
就也没有必要，
OK,
我们聊远了，
现在先回到拳技，
文化漫谈部分，
文化漫谈，
我们刚才，
说到它是一碗，
人人都会喝的白粥嘛，
那我们现在聊一聊，
这碗白粥，
是怎么熬出来的，
首先是，
符号层面，
拳技呢，
它借用了，
很多低门槛的，
传统文化词汇，
比如说，
茶具和香薰，
它们的核心的价值呢，
在我看来，
不是视觉层面的喜好，
而是,
满足情绪上，
心理上的深层需求，
就是,
无冲突，
仪式感，
和象征性，
那,
我个人，
为什么会对，
香气和茶具，
这两个点，
印象那么深刻呢，
是因为，
嗅觉和动作，
是文化中，
最顽固的两种，
记忆形式，
香薰呢，
就是气味，
它唤起的是，
时间层的记忆，
就像那个，
呃,
不知道叫什么，
追意思，
所以年华，
就是普鲁斯特，
就是他所写的那种，
对,
也是这种，
这个意思，
所以,
香薰呢，
它就会，
被我们，
和家,
节日,
庙堂,
这些概念，
关联在一起，
然后,
茶具的意义，
我觉得是在于手势，
是,
欺茶,
喝茶的动作行为，
它唤起的是，
行为层的，
秩序记忆，
一种,
缓慢,
节制的节奏，
我觉得，
全继将，
这两者，
纳入到空间叙事，
就可以激活，
中国人，
身体,
就是,
经验当中的那个，
理的那部分，
哪怕我们，
早就已经，
不再泡茶，
也不焚香，
但,
经过世卫环境，
家庭影响的，
这个,
这种训练，
嗯,
仪式,
相关的这些，
深层哲学观，
其实仍然，
被我们留在了，
现代生活当中，
所以,
当香气，
茶具,
这种,
姿态一旦产生，
它就像是，
嗯,
那些,
原本隐形的，
电路的表面，
而,
被安装了一个，
呃,
提示出发，
作用的小灯泡，
幻解了，
我们内心，
深处的一种，
认同感，
有时候，
我们其实，
不是失去了传统，
而是失去了，
传统的，
隐形形式，
而,
这些隐形的结构，
比如说，
秩序啊，
节奏啊，
呃,
和谐,
还有包括气味，
然后物的，
摆放逻辑什么的，
它仍然，
在,
无意识的层面，
是在继续延续的，
那,
全剂的，
香气,
茶具,
字体,
还有目色，
就是,
对这些隐性秩序的，
再出发，
嗯,
哎,
你这么说，
忽然间觉得，
让好了一些，
因为我们没有丢失传统，
只是丢失了，
它的,
显性形式，
那,
呃，虽然我们说，
全剂也，
借用了一些符号啊，
就是,
但是我们说回来做，
呃,
它作为一个，
定位中端的，
连锁酒店，
商业层面，
也不会允许它，
非常深度的，
去呈现，
中式意境，
因为它需要控制成本呀，
所以,
你会看到，
全剂选用的，
竹,
麻,
或者是木材，
它的成本不高麻，
我们现在会，
见到很多，
中式连锁酒店，
或者是民宿，
都借用了这一套，
呃,
那就这一点而言，
全剂是，
十五年前的先锋，
但,
成长的代价就是，
它越大，
就会失去个性，
呃,
这个甚至，
有点讽刺的，
商业规律，
就是,
任何创新的品牌，
做大做强的标志就是，
你成了行业的标准，
大家都来学你，
你成了最大众的，
平均脸，
呃,
全剂刚刚起步的五年内啊，
几乎没有对手，
呃,
但是很快，
后期之秀亚朵，
在二零一八年左右，
就迎头赶上，
甚至可以说，
是全面的，
超过了全剂，
呃,
我们首先先，
引入一个，
指标概念啊，
叫美方收入，
就是Revenue Port Available Room,。
呃,
这是一家酒店，
经营好坏的，
最核心指标，
那,
这个指标本身，
其实就已经把房价，
还有,
都已经考虑了进去。
那,
如果我们去比较，
全剂和亚朵的，
美方收入指标，
你就会发现，
市场在二零一八年前，
后出现了一个，
呃,
排挺大的变化，
那,
二零一八年发生了什么？
嗯,
呃,
就可以说啊，
就是市场的变化，
就是人群的变化，
那人群的变化，
就是人心的变化，
呃,
我不知道大家，
回忆起自己的，
二零一八年，
是个什么状态？
我周围的每个人，
包括我自己，
都在持续加班，
那,
七年前的加班，
和现在的加班，
可能还有点区别，
啊,
我记得，
那几年，
就是有一家大厂，
取消了九九六，
啊,
部分员工还不乐意了，
就因为周末加班，
有加班费啊，
啊,
那,
现在,
市场的普遍，
呼声是躺平，
但那个时候，
人们的精神状态，
是躺不平，
啊,
就,
反映到消费趋势上，
就是,
比如说，
当时,
如果我去旅游城市出差，
赶上周五的话，
我会把机票，
或者是高铁，
啊,
改到周日晚上，
然后,
自费多订两碗的酒店，
就是,
就是逛逛当地，
看看展啊，
如果有朋友在那儿，
会有朋友，
啊,
但通常啊，
就是,
玩了一天之后，
晚上回到酒店，
我就打开电脑，
提前上中，
呵,
所以,
那个阶段，
人是精力充沛，
是有预防的，
就是,
我们用一种，
不必的状态，
去面对工作和生活，
那,
现在回看，
我当时那个安排，
其实,
时间是非常碎片化的，
我好像，
换到了公司的羊毛，
借出差的机会，
出去玩儿了，
但好像，
又莫名其妙的，
加了班，
所以,
工作和生活，
早已经，
交织在一起，
摘不开了，
所以,
那个阶段呢，
我是更偏向亚朵的，
嗯,
因为,
比起,
拳击的，
不打扰，
无为而至，
一个群主，
比如说，
他会制作，
本地的攻略，
而且推荐的，
都是那种，
不扎堆的景点，
那如果，
我太忙了，
没空出去，
亚朵也能给我，
提供一个，
微度价，
比如说，
赠送当地的，
小特产，
一到晚上，
还送一碗粥，
所以,
你就感觉，
啊啊啊，
这个群主好热情啊，
相比之下，
拳击,
怎么好像，
没动静啊，
就怎么割不上了呢，
你说这个，
我想到的一个理论，
但是,
人们对某段经历的，
整体评价，
主要是基于高峰，
也就是说，
你体验当中，
最强烈的时刻，
还有就是，
你体验的结尾，
所感受到的，
那些强度，
而其他的因素啊，
其他的时段，
虽然不会被我们，
完全遗忘，
但是往往是，
不会被纳入到，
评估之中的，
那,
拳击的策略呢，
其实就是，
低差体验，
就low variance experience,。
也就是说，
不同的时间，
地点和情境下，
用户体验的结果，
波动极小，
是一种，
稳定的体验系统，
那它通过这种方式呢，
就可以避免，
互相的峰值，
就使我们对品牌的印象，
可以保持正向，
或者说，
你至少可以保证，
它是中性的。
确实啊，
就是压朵，
就是,
围绕,
就是刚才Jackie说的那个，
当中定律，
去主动造体验的，
就是举个例子，
就是围绕中啊，
就是,
这封中定律的那个，
中是终点的终，
所以,
在旅行的终点啊，
压朵会给早上有急事，
来不及吃早餐的客人，
准备便携的早餐蛋，
其实出差的人，
就是常有这种时刻，
比如说，
为了赶一个早会，
很早就要离开酒店，
这样的体会，
就非常的暖心，
那,
相比之下，
拳技就是中性的，
就是让你觉得不出错嘛，
所以我们研究下来，
就会觉得，
哎呀,
躲是,
啊,
那个封中，
然后那个拳技是，
啊,
就这样，
持续进行，
是不是？
那,
疫情之后呢，
就是消费趋势，
又有了微妙的变化，
那之前我们刚才说了嘛，
是生活和工作的，
交叉和模糊，
说白了，
大家的心态是，
我全都要，
就是微度价，
我也要啊，
就是,
工作生活，
我都没有放弃，
那现在就是，
消费趋于理性，
就我们会重新思考，
自己到底要的是什么，
就不想再为，
荣誉的服务买单，
就比如说我现在吧，
如果,
我的实际功能，
只是解决住宿，
那,
亚朵和拳技之间，
我会选择价格，
偏低的拳技，
就那,
附加的惊喜可以不要，
就是,
一切都分得清清楚楚，
啊,
所以,
我最为个体，
回味到了拳技派，
嗯,
因为在，
质量管理方面，
一致性的重要程度，
是大于惊喜感的，
尤其是连锁服务业，
就是,
用户最怕的是，
同品牌，
不同体验，
尤其是疫情之后，
人们似乎在，
决策方面，
更求稳，
是,
害怕那种，
惊喜变惊吓的情况，
嗯,
对于花出的钱，
花出去的钱，
就更谨慎了嘛，
就生怕花了这个钱，
就换到了最后你说那个惊吓，
那我们刚才说，
亚朵的美防指标，
是超过拳技的，
那其实今天，
依然是这样的格局啊，
这个指标，
并没有说，
因为消费局势的变化，
拳技实现了反超，
但是,
这只是一个效率指标，
但如果去看规模，
拳技的门店数量，
影响力还是遥遥领先于亚朵的，
那亚朵目前还是选择，
在高县城市安宁扎债，
拳技则走向了更多的，
所谓下沉市场，
我们打个引号啊，
因为,
我非常不喜欢下沉市场这个词，
它带这种腐蚀的姿态，
就是我认为，
不方这么评价，
就是从最宏观的战略层面上来说，
拳技选择，
做一家国民酒店，
那对拳技来说，
这个是市场的扩容，
那对我们消费者来说，
就是消费的普及与民主，
比如说现在在新疆的伊尼，
然后在陕西的汉中，
我们都能看到拳技，
甚至是好几家拳技。
这个我非常同意，
就是下沉市场这个词用在这里，
我觉得是有一点点概念错位的，
首先是上与下这种，
二元结构在酒店行业里，
本身就不太适用，
也就是说高消费力，
高文化密度，
然后对应低消费力，
模仿性消费的这种，
那酒店的地理布局，
并不是简单的去按城市等级来划分的，
就是你刚才举的那个例子，
像新疆伊尼，
陕西汉中开拳技，
它是基于中产生活，
和中产移动的半径，
而如果是在，
比如说云南的山里面，
去建高端的度假酒店，
那更不能说它叫做下沉了，
虽然当地的消费力和产值，
它不是一线城市，
但是开酒店的这个情况，
反而会被看作一种高端眼神，
哎呀，这个云南山里，
我想象一下，
这一晚不得两三千块钱，
那走国民路线的拳技，
它的底色到底是怎么样的呢，
就是现在有必要来认识一下，
就是地造出拳技的这家公司，
以及它的创始人，
那拳技背后站着的公司叫华柱，
一家上市公司，
华柱在孵化出拳技之前，
它起家经营的酒店叫汉亭，
所以不知道大家，
是不是知道这件事情，
所以拳技的国民性，
它不是一日之工，
可以说国民性是他们的来处，
那这家公司的创始人，
也很传奇，
它叫技奇，
在创办汉亭之前，
它创办了儒家这个酒店连锁平台，
是的,
就这两个最早的连锁酒店，
背后都有这个人的影子，
那更神奇的是，
它在之前的一份创业项目是协成，
协成现在站在前台的代表人物是梁建章，
但协成最早是四个人一起创立的，
就包括这位技奇，
那这四件客在创办协成之后，
就发现平台上还可以的酒店，
哎，怎么这么少啊，
要么是好了太好，
要么是贵的太贵，
要么就是差的又完全达不到，
旅行者的基本要求，
这是非常典型的，
供几端的不足，
那对于这个共同的发现，
四件客中的技奇选择，
离开协成自己创业，
去做实体酒店，
那一开始的钱怎么办呢，
答案是协成的这几位创始人，
他们的个人投资大概是100万美元，
给到了技奇，
这才有了后来的儒家，
其实这个创业故事，
我感觉还是挺神仙的，
我不是说四件客的有情神仙，
而是这种创业的状态，
首先这四个人都知道，
有这么一个创业机会，
但下手干的是技奇，
那为什么是他呢，
因为这四个人真的是，
天赋秉性都点在不一样的优势树上了，
那梁建章是神统，技术强人，
还有一位是有金融头脑搞投融资的，
后来这个人还有沈南鹏，
后来还做过中国红山资本的合伙人，
那技奇在这几个人中最适合做线下，
为什么这么说呢，
因为协成早期所有的地推，
甚至是拿地，拿批文，
都是技奇搞定的，
我看了他们刺剑客之间的这种分工协作，
就不得不敢谈，
就是个人优势这件事情上，
如果上班他可能还不是特别明显的体现，
但是在创业过程中，
真的是特别特别容易被放大和检验的。
对，你说到协成，
我记得之前你还跟我说过一些协成的发家史，
什么的也挺有意思，
下回有机会的话可以讲一讲，
然后要说他们是同一伯人做的的话，
那还真的是有一种能成事的人，
干什么都能成的感觉。
对，他们各自的背景就都很丰富嘛。
那技奇这个人在酒店行业是一个传奇般的存在，
因为他是非常成功的连续创业者，
他参与的协成儒家，
还有他后来亲手地造的华助，
先后都在纳斯达克上市。
但是这个创始人的曝光度并不高，
就不是所谓的明星企业家，
我也是这次做拳击这个选题，
才知道有这么一位。
不过，就是那个时代的中国，
确实是急速发展，
对于有些人来说是遍地黄金，
有想想协成这几位创始人的口气吧，
就真的很大，就是平台缺什么，
那我们就造一个出来，
就是技奇是一个绝绝对对和时代共舞的人。
我倒是对技奇这个人有印象，
因为以前住拳击酒店的时候，
他每个房间都会放一本创始人自传，
应该就是他吧。
反正单从这个行为就可以看出来，
他其实是很有那种，
就是他有敏锐的品牌感，
因为个人品牌其实也是可以算作在其中的吧。
那技奇这个创始人呢，
曾经给拳击定了一个三无原则，
听着跟他三无商品似的，
但其实是无主题，无中心，无界线。
那拳击总给我一种威而至的感觉，
就相对于亚朵的有，
就刚才我们说了他的风中体验，
就非常会造体验，
那相对于亚朵的有，
拳击就是无，
但是他好像就是想通过无，
这个形式去达到无界线的渗透，
就像我们刚才一直说的白周这个遗乡，
就是中餐中的白周，
他非常的忠实，
但是不嫌不淡，他也不往生里去，
但是从南到北，人人都在和他。
你说这个东西很到家呀，
就是大道无形无名那种感觉，
他和我们文化里的一些底层逻辑很像，
我觉得，
就可能拳击就是用这种无的方式，
在维持一种看不见的平衡，
而这种平衡，
它正触到我们文化里那些，
虽然今天已经不再被说明，
但其实还在我们身体里去延续的东西，
就是有一种观点，
它叫做文化的内引结构，
它指的是即使社会形态发生局面，
某些符号或者是行为逻辑仍然会在。
日常时间中被继承，
只不过它是脱离了原始的语境了，
像拳击用的视觉元素，还有茶具什么的，
我知道可能有的人会说，
它是一种表层姿态，
而在品牌的语境当中，
姿态往往被视为表演嘛，
但我觉得表演所使用的符号，
与文化潜意是吻合的时候，
人们就是会感知到真实，
因为姿态触发了我们的深层神经，
结果就是像网上开玩笑说的，
我们忽然间就血脉觉醒了，
血脉觉醒，这个形容还挺误会的，
我感觉它是一种开关被拨通的感觉，
我记得我在国外生活了那几年，
有一天，
看见了一条24节气的朋友圈，
以及对应的那天应该吃什么，
那我当时脑海中就浮现出了风雾这个词，
我不知道英文如何呈现风雾这个词，
因为它不只是一种食材，
它是一种最匹配自然的节奏，
它也会让我想到舌尖上的中国，
然后它会让我想到脉浪，
会让我想到，
雨滴应该是按照一种很优美的姿态落下来，
都非常有画面感的，
和我们文化相关的意境，
但是触发开关的就是节气这两个字，
就是你刚才说它脱离了原始雨晶，
那节气它本来可能和农业相关，
和种地有关，
就我也不种地，
但它依然会让我感受到它，
所以说全技是有意识的，
提供了这个唤醒的机会，
对,
我觉得这种尝试和找寻的过程，
是很积极的，
就像前面提到过，
东方有的时候是被他者化的概念，
是被观看的对象，
而将美学进行现代化，
具体比如说像提炼符号，
发掘深层的文化脉络，
像刚才卉斯说的节气这些东西，
它就能让我们参与到，
对东方主题的叙述与定位的重构之中，
去修正，
甚至去主导这个，
本就属于我们的东西，
然后也可以去展示我们自己的一种混合性，
还有现代性的价值，
而拳技之所以被我们接受，
可能也正是因为它，
某种层面上，
实现了消费者所需要的文化上的自我构建。
可能我们在生活中的很多时刻，
都需要重新和我们的文化建立联系。
说到这大家有没有，
一些突然血脉觉醒的时刻呢，
突然明明确确的觉得，
我真是个耿古上的中国人，
也欢迎大家给我们留言，
分享在拳技的住宿体验，
或者出差小故事。
好了，那这期就是这样，
我们下期见，
拜拜,